Hi, my name is Stephanie Liu,
and I work on the YouTube APIs
and Tools team.
Today, I'll be going over some
simple examples using the new
player APIs and the Chromeless
player. First, a little bit
of background.  Before, if you
wanted to embed a YouTube
video onto your site all you
could do is choose one of our
standard embedder players, and
put it there. As a developer,
you really didn't have any
insight about what was going
on.  Now, you'll be able to do
much more. The JavaScript and
Flash APIs that we've just
released, will allow you to
control our embedded players.
Issue commands like play,
pause, seek to a specific
position in a video, mute, set
volume; get data, like current
time, and how far the video is
buffered. You can also
subscribe to events like
changes in the player state.
Now, the Chromeless player is a
swf with no player controls.
So, no YouTube buttons or our
progress bar. You can put in
your own buttons and customize
it to fit in with the look and feel of
your site. OK, so, let's get
started with what the
JavaScript player API can do.
So, here we have the regular
YouTube embedded player. I
think everyone's probably
pretty familiar with this.
It plays and now I'm gonna
show you how to set up this
embed so that we can make API
calls to it. The first thing
you need to do is include
"swfobject.js". Now, I
recommend using a swfobject
because it makes embedding
Flash content a lot easier.
It'll take care of things for
you like detecting the user's
version of Flash. They're
going to need version 8 or
above to be able to see your
player correctly. Now here, is
the div that the embed is
gonna to live in. You'll notice
we're calling it "ytapiplayer,"
we're going to need that
later. And, if they don't have
8 or above installed, they'll
just see this line of text
instead of a broken player.
Now we're kinda getting into
the meat of it. Here is where
we're actually going to set up
the embed object.
You see here,
the parameters that we're
gonna have in the embed object.
We need
"allowScriptAccess: "always"".
This means the YouTube swf can
make calls to your HTML page.
And your HTML page can make
calls to the player swf. One
of the attributes we wanna set
is id for "myytplayer". This
is gonna be the name of the
embedded object. You can use
this to get a reference to the
player via JavaScript using
get element by id later on.
Now "swfobject.embedSWF" will
actually load the player from
YouTube and embed it on your
HTML page. Let me just go over
all the parameters that you
need here. The first parameter
is the URL of the swf.
"enableksopi=1,"  just
enables the player to
receive API calls.
Now "playerapiid" is the
parameter that's going to be
passed to "onYouTubePlayerReady"
as the first argument
when the player is loaded and
ready to go. Now you want to
name the player because if you
are expecting multiple videos
to be loaded on your page,
you'll want to know which one
has just told you that it's
ready. The second parameter
here is the id of the HTML div
that the embed is going to
live in. As you'll notice,
this is "ytopiplayer," that we
called up here. Then we got
width, height, and the
required version of Flash that
the user needs. So remember
that they need "8" or above to
be able to see your content
correctly. And then a couple
of optional parameters we're
not going to use. And the
parameters and attributes we
set up here. Okay, now that
the embed is set up to receive
API calls, let's do something
a little bit more interesting.
Let's enter some commands.
So here I've added
a couple of links
We can control the player
using these instead of the
buttons. I'll play and pause
it. Stop. Mute. Unmute. And
so let me show you the really
simple calls that need to be
made to set this up. As I was
saying before, once the player
is loaded and ready to go, its
going to call
"onYouTubePlayerReady."
So here we're defining the
function. And we're just going
to grab the reference to the
player and store it, so that we
can issue API calls to it. With
that, we're ready to actually
start making things happen.
So this is how we set up those
links. This is really simple,
just a link with an "onclick"
to this play function. And
this is how we've defined it.
We're just doing a little
error checking, making sure
it's not null, and then
calling "ytplayer.playVideo."
It's that simple. Similarly,
with pause we got
".pauseVideo," "stop,"
"stopVideo," and then "mute"
and "unmute." It's as simple
as that to issue these
commands to the player. Now
that we've issued some basic
commands, let's try to take
some input and seek to 90
seconds into this video.
And this is just as easy as
the other commands, and I'll
show you how to do that.
So here's a little form we
made to get user input on how
many seconds to seek to in the
video. We're calling the
"seekTo" function here and
we're just grabbing the value
in the text box. And here's
how we're defining the
function, very similar to what
we did in before
"ytplayer.seekTo." The
seconds we just passed in and
whether or not we want to make
a new request to the server if
the "seekTo" position is
beyond the loaded video. So
now that we've issued commands
to the player, let's try to get
some data from it. Useful data
to have is what the current
time of the player is, how far
the user is in the video. So
if we hit play here, you'll
see that the current time div
here is updating.
So to constantly display the
current time of the video, we
are going to go back to
"onYouTubePlayerReady." We're
going to add an interval for
every 250 milliseconds. So
every 250 milliseconds is
going to be called
"updateCurrentTime," which
just calls
"ytplayer.getCurrentTime" and
updates the HTML. You can also
get other data like the
duration of the video, the URL
of the video, and the embed
code.  So now that we've
issued commands to the player,
gotten data from it. Let's see
how we can subscribe to events.
In this case, let's have the
player tell us every time it
changes it's state. So right
here you can see that the
player is in state 5, which is
video queued. If I hit play,
it goes into buffering and
then to 1, which is playing.
I pause it, it goes into 2
and so on. So let me show you
how to subscribe to an event.
Now if we want to constantly
show the current player state,
we're going to go back to
"onYouTubePlayerReady" and
we're going to add an event
listener by saying
"ytplayer.addEventListener."
We're going to subscribe to
the "onStateChange" event.
And the "onStateChange" event
is going to use our callback
function right here and pass
it the current state.
And here we are just updating
the HTML. Now you know the
basics of the JavaScript API.
How to issue commands, how to
get data, and how to listen
for events. The Flash APIs
have all the same calls and
the same functionality, but
loading the YouTube players
swf into another swf is a
little trickier. Because of
the architecture of the
player's swf, using the action
script's built-in
"MovieClipLoader" will not
give you accurate information
about when the player is ready.
So, here's a snippet of code
that loads the YouTube player
into Flash. We create a new
"MovieClipLoader" here.
Then we load a YouTube swf
into it and call it "ytPlayer."
This listener will check every
250 milliseconds whether the
player is loaded or not. Now
this is the extra call that is
not in the JavaScript API.
"ytplayer.isPlayerLoaded" is
what you should use in action
script to check if a player is
loaded or not. Once this is
true, we can go ahead and do
all the things I talked about
before with the JavaScript API,
like addEventListeners.
Now that you know all about
our Player APIs, let's talk
about the Chromeless Player.
As I was saying before, the
Chromeless Player is just a
swf with no buttons. You can
customize it to look however
you want. So for example, on
this site they're using the
Chromeless Player. Using their
own buttons, and then using
the player APIs to control it.
So here's an example, very
similar to what we had before
except that we're using the
Chromeless Player. You'll
notice that the buttons are
gone and the progress bar.
All that's left is the YouTube
logo here in the bottom right
hand corner. It uses the same
JavaScript APIs that we've
been talking about, so I can
control it with this links.
Play. Pause And you already
pretty much know how to set this
up, except that the swf URL is
different. So let me show you
that right now. So one thing
that's different about the
Chromeless Player from the
regular embedded player is
that you need a developer key
to access it. So if you don't
have a developer key, head
over to code.google.com and
get one. It's free and really
easy to sign up. Now this code
should look really familiar
to you. The only difference
between embedding the
Chromeless Player in a page
and embedding a regular
YouTube embedded player,
is the swf URL. So you can
see here the URL for the
Chromeless Player swf is
gdata.youtube.com/apiplayer.
Here's where you put your
developer key.
And then the other two
parameters are the same.
So now that you know how to
load up the Chromeless Player,
let me point out a few
differences from the regular
JavaScript API. You'll see
here this is actual what the
Chromeless swf looks like when
you first load it when you
first load it cause it doesn't
have a video id in it yet.
So there's a load video id
function that we can call.
And there it goes. There's
also a queue video function
that you can call. So this
just loads the thumbnail and
grab the video, but doesn't
start playing. To load a new
video into the Chromeless
Player, we just call a
"ytplaer.loadVideoById," pass
it in "id," and optionally
where in the player we want it
to start at. Similarly, for
"cueNewVideo,"  we call
"ytplaer.cueVideoBGyId," pass
the "id," and where in the
video we want it to start once
the player has issues a play
command. Hopefully, this give
you a good idea about what
these new tools are and what
you can do with them. There
are a lot of things I didn't
cover here, so be sure to
check out the documentation
on code.google.com